a 2vs2 a liquid have the advance in
there trying to bring it down to the two
versus one if it's our PK this drop they
come in serious trouble
that's the fourth map the favorites
coming over have just unlock the end of
words
come on Annabelle Annabelle the adorable
touchable
sixty-three days it's almost
inconceivable teamliquid through raw
skill and will are your ESL one colored
2019 Jaffe
well guys I can hardly believe it but
that is it for ESL one cologne for
another year the Cathedral of
counter-strike has closed its doors but
not before a crowning teamliquid as the
undisputed best team in the world now
the major that isn't a major at a ton of
unforgettable moments not the least of
which was liquid winning that Grand Slam
but we also got the rise of a French
prodigy in xilu the rise of the creek
and the beginning of the end of tenure
or a true legend I I can't really get
out the words that I'm feeling right now
but super happy to be here still I'm
just very happy that still people are
supporting me supporting an opinion
we've got the best of the group stage
the best of the playoffs and of course
that great grand final coming up but
first the best funny moments and fails
from ESL one cologne 2019 come back
around flame Ian Zeus Zeus goes down but
which gets back in with the AWP map
looking to be confirmed nearly simple of
course try to push it through a few
moments later I think it's happening the
game that was on a silver platter it was
a done deal it was the map for na'vi
it's going to overtime he taps on a zeus
pistol as well the knife does cost them
and liquid take the game in overtime I
mean simple just through it a game for
them I'm sorry but it's true
I mean he also knows that as well you're
plenty like [ __ ] [ __ ] I think he's
lost his gun I think he threw off the
edge a genuine he's lost a sin spawn
stuff he's just nice oh it's got stuck
in the barrel he literally has no gun
right because he surely he can't get
anything done and it's falling apart
nitro can't win this it's going to be
that point for NRG and the liquid looks
like him might just fall short
nitro might not be able to save either
okay oh wow ok he can save he can say
they don't know he's here
don't pull the trigger save the or we
Russian are we doing sneaky beauty like
fun gets one kill but take that's
actually he's going beyond hide
teabagging he's gone into something that
should have age restrictions on it
that's actually like a problem you
should notify your school it will never
be the same as someone speaking the
native language just never but then so
how do you justify phases successes that
we were just talking about the New York
everyone this guy called knee choice to
shoot ever in the head that's all God he
needs to get an open shoe everyone if
there's anyone alive really to shoot
them all all off my students there
anyone is there any leftover I'll give a
cure I think how can used to go well
done great hold and Guardian wins out
the round after the timeout
that's much better yang Coast please
once the fist pump may not get it going
for it again still not gonna get it
might try and get it doesn't get it all
and raise exchange the device have the
chance JW other chance I thought if JW
I've been able to get the bomb and we're
this hauling out this is not gonna be
live this is a stop there is a player
from one of the other games actually
enjoy
the wrong service we're just gonna get
things restarted um and he's that like
some sort of Freudian slip
yeah I think I lost just forgot he was
on phase watch for plop I pay his name's
great isn't it it probably sounds really
cool but like in English it's like wow
like that's like it's like the sound
poop makes when it hits the ground yeah
when a bird like a pigeon is it be
interested no it's the Swedish word that
is no this is on the rise they've just
signed the contracts kind of a bit of a
false start this one ends obviously
going out last place I I would if I
hadn't seen the brackets I would have
said these guys are off the playoffs
minimum playoffs or it just shows how
that's where the teams like ni p like
heroic that's why they being able to get
their runs they Dean able to go all the
way up there and that's enough of that
how could they he's why I think he's
wondering this rounds for Adelaide oh
maybe not hold on wait wait he's gonna
line up both he's gonna be the star
player yeah he needs to make sure he has
the line of thought that's the hard part
and tarik what are you gonna do here
this defense is just getting overrun
apex is already in the site he's got to
do this he's got to do it on the trigger
discipline thing
sing it all for Terry and nothing at all
for NRG they're making it expensive but
I still can't see how we could win this
he's gonna try to get this gonna just
leave and oh we've all been there we've
all felt that frustration oh that simple
knife that is something we won't forget
for a long time but now it's time to
move on to the highlights the best ace
is the best clutches the sickest plays
starting with the group stage he
actually stays away but if they bounce
it off the wall he could do damage and
look at all the HP return oh there's the
orchid a from all three kills how was
the grenadiers a nuclear bomb absolutely
destroyed the whole team 14th round it
seems with just the USPS coming for him
to make a wall although that's such a
leave right here the pistols were doing
for free and pretty disgusting shot and
he's just jiggle peeking them out okay
to get this killed and that might just
be it they're trying to see if they get
that the views yet attacked up both of
them it's another one versus three
shorty this one they can win they line
up for he's gonna get one and he's gonna
follow it up unbelievable they have no
reason to extend the cross they want to
take this map and get themselves in such
a close position to get the semi-finals
in step though forests they both expose
themselves at the exact same time he
rips his way from just with a deagle and
the trees more not gonna happen and
steal an almost impossible task is so
much to do with 5hp bomb down but they
do not have a kid but they know he's
like oh my god he knows he's off the
bomb as well he might do this electronic
he will be tested Stewie does he go all
the way around with no kid man I think
he's done enough even he kills Stewie
now he went on earth time gonna be views
he saw his shoulder this is amazing from
Stuart you're on flame he was
unbelievable you're right he did that as
fast as he had to had to be a head shot
5 HP nails it to the target
and all they're gonna go towards tackle
this could be the meat grinder that yeah
p9 2 kills commit a third is their
attacker run to the battle but he
switches to the D door looking for the
anti-choice and there it is tack your
deals with it well all five players four
kills how this pans out no one coming in
hauls much he's they're not gonna be put
into play quite yet the boiler holy they
line up for Sergei he gets a third it's
over shuts it down oh my god picking
that one up like Sabine okay anything it
falls on an owl ooh to see what he can
find it it's to chose he looks back
speaking at the triple there it is won't
be one
owl who can win this friends off the
back of pistols ports have to get the
time solo little sapphic surely falls
hero has worn it what a play from Oulu
there we go
a triple and nasty one about we do
pretty nice work guys he's actually
looking there he's actually I didn't see
it well it is on the clutch minister
himself sippin 20 seconds and he's
creeping around they're gonna pick up
the palm pretty close to him I am
actually now a little bit scared JW on
the other side if he misses a shot
that's the bomb that's gonna go down sip
is waiting for it he could shoot under
the tree but he's gonna go for it
now running out is he gonna be able to
catch him he's waiting for it and
instead of overextending he's gonna see
if he can flash his way into this one he
knows that twist must be down there all
the job and that's almost the shot on JW
I can't believe he's still alive now up
on top hunting him down and the Molotov
burning in my ways sip now in a
one-on-one down on the palm and he's
gonna tap it and just hold it down he's
gambling on it he's holding it all the
way it's wrist is gonna be sold oh god
he's too late one versus three look at
that little smile so Zeus Oh
flamie crisper flaming it's just playing
aimbots as they walk down the heat is
been turned up by the young man it's not
the good start if they want they just
have to convert the pistol win they
can't do that and that's what fake it's
down right back up and look at that
dizzying lines up to absolutely insane
chaps it follows it up and big just
dismantle my PR to that position you
can't escape so he's got to be very
careful nitro meanwhile knows that they
are heading back over to where the
tunnels instead he'll find a third for a
lovely fourth another 4 K for him yeah
for electronic they're trying to buy him
some space here we get his stuff back
there Shaun the obvious 3 set and he
does electronic wasn't fast enough and
all my goodness carry and we talked
about the OP potential there it is
that's why he's so good as he gets the
ACE as well he gets the ace that is such
a big play for me I'm told in the course
though Alex should fall here Oh short
from Alex headshot connects and Crim's
is on the floor Gill comes back if it's
went to the other side of the mat but
Alex certainly making the place must be
going slow proud to this point there's
the headshot to twist this would be
incredible the quad kill clutch coming
right through as exists will stand on
the bombsite alex has a career angle to
deal with it's the bonus planted for him
there's the tap its effect on Alex Peaks
realizes he's on perform he played it
well Alex makes the clutch happen and
vitality will head into the lead
Joseph Roland si will eventually drop
them on the floor but it has to be the
one before questions I would
it comes in barely enough health to
survive here on brawler but so he wants
to kill there's the headshot pulled the
back knee up and sideways got the triple
crimps is the last man standing and
there's time for the diffuse so IRA
wants to smoke the bomb if you're crazy
you have to be scared and cyber wins it
that is unbelievable from the young
frenchman as team vitality will get a
16th
well you've waited this long and here it
is the resurgence of french CS
coronation of teamliquid the best from
the playoffs and the grand finals of the
major that is in a major job ladies and
gentlemen here we go energy and vitality
the first quarter finally of ESL one
cologne I can't wait to get this game
underway and they need a bureau
performance out of Apex right now
otherwise this is gonna be another bomb
side lost for them he's so flashed
inside we're gonna be there to try and
pick it up does get the second kill and
somehow turns it oh he's get one more
headshot to take down Stanislaw and
finally circus gonna be there 14 seconds
left behind the pillar waiting it's
gonna be so quick that's the quad kill
cycle saving them a good double kill for
him and now it's all on cyber here 14
seconds left Oh oh no the pompon it
might be right in front and now we just
need to wait they can't find the pump
anymore terrorists get it so I was back
for more looking for him already with
the triple just needs one more clicker
less common tarik is hiding behind
Tetris I wonder who's got to backwalk
kills winning it for my charity you've
never seen anything like it
you're defending champions of ESL one
cologne are present admittedly the water
finals and such a monster of a marathon
is ahead of them if they want to go
ahead and defend that title truly need
time running low there's the Scout it
looks like and I fear us you to take
this round three versus one time is just
not there for electronic but the frag is
can't even get the bomb down at this
point yes five seconds but he's gonna
try and fade it out now he can plod he
can still get it down he can still get
it down one versus one rats he didn't
push and now electronic has the
advantage he saw his head he saw me
knows he's there he goes back up
did y'all ever see he just barely got
that plant off risky with the stack I
think he thought they were further down
I think yes no don't be and simple
through the smoke point whoops keys well
he's just gonna watch forward CT with
the nwp smoke from his teammate he gets
through four steps off the end of the
world he only had three on entry boost
up Layton flowerpot they're looking that
direction claiming it home right now
it's get my time to come alive yes we've
done it so many times it might be the
last but he's gonna go it's electronic
gets well at an 8 but get right jumped I
don't think he spotted boom [ __ ] I
don't think they know exactly where he
is at all my boo is just gonna walk back
no take him down and he goes back into
the same position it's too far gone rez
runs it in binge cuz this bombs gonna go
off to 237 HP and times run out now they
are in to the semi-final versus liquid
to over over n IP I play this game for
20 years they've done greatest game for
so such a long time it means the world
to me the SP standing here I can't
really get out the words that I'm
feeling right now but I'm super happy to
be here still I did it I didn't know
this would be so painful for me but I'm
just very happy that still people are
supporting me supporting
the first time these two top 10 teams
meet is in the semi-finals of the Laxus
arena ESL one cologne turnaround there's
only one player it's our PK he's not
watching that
oh this backstab this has set a
beautifully device doesn't even need to
fight hit glaive he's gonna get it he's
gonna cry 3 there is someone inside
caves it mix is watching for a flight
but device might just go down for free
yes it was a bit of a struggle but that
has got to be head scratching for
Astralis why is he there at this moment
and how do you deal with it apex is
gonna get another and now he can retreat
it's a retreating battle but only goes
back for more
hey Becks they're gonna they can pull
back this a very small play for Estrada
so he's gonna catch will shut them down
a triple and suddenly it's in his favor
sip is right behind him I don't know if
I BK knows that but he's very low and
help as well he's gonna have to make a
little bit of noise and now he is
becoming a big shot just he wins it one
versus three and a poor kill they rushed
it you have a three man stuck on this
side device just had a really rough game
flashed he's gonna get that shot and it
has to feel a little bit going out
middle of the air to take down Alex
another push ago
every single one from nothing to the
antique WPS he's selling xilu I was here
all year as one of the best hoppers in
the world and I can deliver just as good
and look at this shot they line up for
him it's so unlikely but it's beautiful
in all five kills so close for vitality
but they cannot win again no it
shouldn't be possible but somehow they
get the bomb Claude Dupree
all he needs is a single bullet but I
became the fight they can't be real
let's jump in Team Liquid vs. Navi that
first game I think it's given the Navi
the belief
I mean unfound completely founded belief
they can win this and they can beat this
team if by design
stewey he's gonna move up close range
AWP there's only one and they all come
back they all have range they all have
the ball in front of them but the shots
are coming in for liquid suddenly goes
down it's just poets even simple
couldn't surprise my swinging back out
full HP on the last player and poets get
that bone is the shot from play Nihal
gods that is spectacular
oh my goodness maybe that's even better
to kick things off it's due to K brew
the door takes down the sniper and
simple hits the deck and the scalp it
we've got to see that through the doors
and evita straight up wall bang them it
didn't even show face that is such an
amazing move from Stewie 2k I agree
Moses suffit they're trying to
capitalize with this force by remember
they've got every dollar in this round
and they know that they're gonna slow
things down boom [ __ ] gone behind the
core Zeus wants back out claiming he'd
snap a twist got him back twist with the
deagle he's got Zeus and it's electronic
forced to go into suicide to grab the
bomb and it is a suicidal moving D
because up close
[Applause]
I've never say that if they like it
Swiss with a desert eagle from Hal vas
nitros pretty much flying solo at this
points to who's already rotating back
twist is still at the bottom of the
stairs for a fast flank but they remain
a man down in 31 seconds major changes
that with the matter this ports do water
round with the AWP team liquid on one
side of the stage and team vitality on
the other an arena full of 15,000
passionate eSports fans and they know
it's time for the grand final max comes
out to finish the job get to it seems we
as he hopes twist even gets one at rings
damages - how does twist for the second
say whoa he peeked out 8k available he's
gonna grab it on the run and he's got
the ball him he's got armor this is a
street 102 but alex is twists whisper
threes in the finals didn't go their way
last year he didn't show up on the big
stage he's turn this he has the gun he's
using the deagle he's got confidence in
his name and he sees depth another
former black quick find as I watch the
push through nitro okay didn't catch a
Mexican alex is still here though
and nap it's good nights does not want
to repeat too soon Nath at the car good
response from a pax another step further
he might not have had the ankle or be
alive but the round for vitality back
down again and side were to get the ball
back again we said double overtime he
said out a possibility is an
unbelievably impossible but it might be
was I who finally it exhaust like that
as he stepped back into the door anyone
plant there's no rush
slow it down as now the second map for
vitality manages to read that and catch
out Alex without losing HP continuing to
try and find more ground continuing to
try burned around to a crisp heads I who
has to shine through and a woman to he's
got the first anything create Sherman
goes down that's gonna be a nightmare as
the bomb tries to go down God it's the
only way still what a shot it was and
they get the bomb down that fair play at
least don't know how he does that but
still very impressive all the same apex
the link connector side were with a
flash at their best hope now and
Stewie's been caught but night shows
there that he gets doing
should we get away on 14 it's one thing
for nitro to trade
it's another dis a miscreant friend his
teammate get the round all the once a
chance to clutch low HP for both players
remaining but he himself sits on 56 and
the time suggests they're waiting for
the rotation which means they're waiting
for the split and ilish has to play this
to perfection smoke on his right tap on
the ball straight through eight HP and
Alex is forced to move forced to get
away
Chili's knows everything three steps
ahead any championship point for liquid
well guys that is it for the best of ESL
one cologne I can't believe we have to
wait another year to experience the
magic of the major that isn't a major
but you don't have to wait another year
to experience the magical content that
the score esports produces each and
every single week so hit that sub button
hit the like button let us know in the
comments below
what you want to see us cover next and I
will see you next time
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]